All right, well, the HTML is a critical resource. And the CSS style sheet
inside is also going to be render blocking.
The image doesn't block, the critical rendering path.
And this JavaScript file at the end is also asynchronous and it won't block
rendering. So in total, that's going to be
two critical resources, the HTML and the CSS.
>> You nailed it.
>> Now, I didn't ask you about the number
of critical bytes, but any idea how you would go
about figuring that out?
>> Simple. I just need to know the size of the HTML and the CSS files.
>> Yup, exactly.
>> Now, what about the critical path length?
>> So, let's see, the HTML file is 1. We have
another round trip to get to CSS. And then, because this
JavaScript file is async, it's not going to block rendering. So, the
best case is going to be two, as our critical path length.
>> That's right.